but i will say trump does have one thing
going for him right now and that one
thing of course is the fact that his
poll numbers are looking better and
there was another new poll out this week
that i want to talk about for just a
minute because i think it's worthwhile
because this is exceptionally creepy
following
the fbi's execution of the search
warrant down there at mar-a-lago
what trump calls of course the raid
donald trump's
favorability
among republicans
increased now we know that there's
nothing you know surprising about that
but listen to this
this is according to an nbc news poll as
reported by the hill
republicans who support former president
trump more
than they support the gop
climbed to 41 percent in august
up seven points from may when 34 percent
said they supported trump more than the
party
a slim majority of republicans or 50
percent say they support the party more
than they do trump the poll finds but
that's down from 58 percent
in may
so we went from a 24 point gap
of republicans who said they love the
party more than they love trump to now a
nine-point gap
of republicans who say they love the
party more than they love trump
now think about what that means for just
a moment here
right
these are republican voters so outside
republican world you know
election
applications of this poll don't really
exist
this
means
that you have 41 percent
of republicans out there based on this
poll
who say that my loyalty is not to a
political party
it's not to the office of the government
it is to donald j
trump
that guy
that spends all his time golfing and
complaining about things online
that's where my loyalty is
i look at him and i just
um
right i see it i feel it
the power coming off of that man
um that's
nuts and i think it's time we just say
things like that right we just have to
come out every now and then
call it what it is and just say that's
nuts
but that is what today's gop is you know
we we saw it with liz chaney losing by
like 40 points last week we see it
with the way these republicans react
anytime donald trump gets in trouble
you know the individuals showing up and
wanting to attack the fbi a building
filled with people with extensive
firearms training
and they're like oh yeah i'm going to
take them all on yeah it didn't end well
for any of them
but that's how much they love donald
trump that's what they're willing to do
it doesn't matter if it seems crazy to
us to them it seems normal
and that's what we're up against on the
other side and that is why these people
are so dangerous
we got to take another break again i am
farron cousins you find me on youtube at
youtube.com slash fair and balanced
youtube.com slash the ring of fire
twitter facebook and instagram at fair
and balanced this is the david pakman
show and we'll be right back